so let's go to an in Austin Texas hi and
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up um going Colin today to maybe get
some encouragement a little bit I'm just
kind of down in the dumps about our
financial situation we've been on the
dave plan for about two years and just
feels like we're not making any headway
we was on a very strict budget we budget
every month but it seems like every
month something comes up this month it's
like $1,000 car repairs last month it
was Christmas and even though we
budgeted ahead of time for Christmas it
still was Christmas you know and it no I
don't I don't know if you budgeted ahead
of time for it why was Christmas or
crisis it wasn't a crisis and and we did
not have wanted to throw your budget
often it didn't it didn't really throw
it off it was more like we had family in
town and little things like that added
up you know sure about girls
those kind of things yeah it seems that
it was family being in town cause you to
spend money it did yeah a little bit and
what were yeah um you know go on get
something to eat you know even though we
we never eat out that so that was like
Dave Anza sack of beans and I'm funny we
never we went out to eat a couple of
times you know what is your hopefully
was your household income okay um well
I'm stay-at-home mom and my husband
brings in about three grand a month
all this right here she is - she's - all
right he's bringing in three thousand
dollars a month that's ten and I and I
do I do some little babysitting outside
the home sometimes
so she was take home pay is three
thousand dollars a month is that what
you're saying yes sir how much is your
rent we we own our own home which is
probably for living in Austin we're
really got a pretty good deal when we
bought this house
how much entertainment we have 8021 -
how much is your payment one is a
thousand and the other one is 260 okay
so you have a 1260 dollar payment with a
three thousand dollar take-home pay we
just figure out your problem
yes sir better house for we are house
poor but we're right on them so you're
not on the Dave Ramsey plan that was an
inaccurate statement because I would
never have recommended someone stay with
a house payment 50% of their take-home
pay for two years it's mathematically
directions we used to make more we used
to make more than when I just decided to
stay home with the baby and you decided
don't ever mention what you decided to
do I don't know where we would live in
Austin for that amount of money because
cheaper like very expensive in Austin
okay you're telling me no we're in
Austin there's anything that you can
rent cheaper than twelve hundred sixty
dollars I'm sorry that's just simply not
true not really where I'd want to live
oh now we're down into it okay so what
is your husband's prospects of getting
his income up I think that's really what
I call Dave um I can't I try really hard
to encourage him to look for something
else and he just he just can't do it he
can't think to do it he's so tired when
he comes home and you know he community
commutes an hour each way to work
everyday
that's unreal yeah what does he work hmm
where does he work
where does he we're nowhere what's one
area where it was an hour from Austin
it's in Austin we live on one end Austin
that's on the other end Austin him all
right what here's the problem okay you
guys feel stuck you particularly feels
like you're stuck with a toddler at home
which is enough to drive anyone if
they've got a lot of money crazy but
when you're broken you got a toddler too
it's really enough to get you so it's
just hard
now so what we have to do is something
has to change and I don't know exactly
which one you're going to change but if
you don't change something you're going
to keep getting what you've been getting
right absolutely okay number one your
perception of housing is completely
false
it's mythology the fact that no one in
Austin Texas lives in a house under
$1,200 is absolutely crazy now you guys
are going to move into a neighborhood
that you can afford to live in whether
you want to live there or not or you're
going to go back to work
or he's going to get a different career
one of these things is going to happen
or you're going to eventually get in
deep financial trouble because a house
payment that is 50% of your take-home
pay never leads to anything long-term
except deep financial trouble this is
why you're freaked out because you can
do math you know so now so the two of
you are going to have to sit down and
come up with some action steps either
and creates an income a big income her
husband has a different career track and
or extra jobs we move on the end of town
where he lives so he's not so freaking
tired that he can think about doing
something else we moved to a cheaper
house or some combination of those
variables you guys are going to have to
take action this is not going to get
better because we walk around saying
we're on the Dave Ramsey plan and don't
go out to eat those aren't the problems
is that logical well absolutely I only
said that because I didn't want you to
think that we were living you know I
appreciate that okay I just didn't want
people to think that that's what I
endorse so that's why I had to correct
it so no I know here's the thing here's
the thing I I think that you're scared
and you're beat up and I think he's
tired so I think tonight you had to put
the baby fully fed to bed early and the
two of you are gonna have to turn the
television off and think about 2015 and
say okay something's going to give let's
decide what's going to give before it's
decided for us and talk about it because
there's three or four things on the
table the length of the commute and this
is in five minutes of talking to you
it didn't take a long time to get to the
bottom of you know what the problems are
is what I'm telling you it's the length
of the commute the lack of income that
he has the lack of income that the
household has lack of a career path that
he has and your house payments to hire a
percentage of your income so if you're
going to stay in that house he needs to
get a different job and you may need to
get a job on he needs to get one on that
side of town otherwise you need to sell
this house and you think about a
different way to live so that you can
live life's too short to live like
you're living it's no fun this house
owns your butt and it just it's not
worth it so I think his income needs to
go up I'm with you on that I'll put you
guys through Financial Peace University
if you've not been hold on Kelly will
pick up and we'll help you we'll walk
with you through this but you're going
to have to make some tough decisions
both of you
you